what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder and it's about to
go down this weekend at d23 today is
Disney plus day so happy Disney plus day
but really what we're waiting for is two
days from now Saturday September 10th
where Marvel Studios has their panel at
d23 to talk about all of their upcoming
projects and of course as we get closer
and closer the reports start to come out
and today it seems like we could have
our biggest reports yet and of course
they are about casting news lately over
the past couple of weeks and really over
the past year depending on what project
you're talking about we've been getting
a lot of info about certain actors who
are going to be playing certain roles
like John Krasinski playing Mr Fantastic
which we eventually saw just not in the
main universe but now that some projects
have been confirmed like Nova an
official release date has been given for
the Fantastic Four project which means
the Fantastic Four casting should come
soon and with rumors going around that
Henry Cavill has has been cast for
something people are really wondering
what d23 has in store for us but today I
think it gets a little bit more serious
two days before Marvel's d23 panel we
have some very very interesting rumors
that have come out specifically
involving the casting of the Fantastic
Four the casting of Henry Cavill and the
casting of Nova now of course as always
with the rumor mill take this info with
a grain of salt sometimes rumors are
true but of course sometimes they end up
not being true even if they do come from
somewhat of a reliable source but let's
take this first one for example the
first one is coming from John Campion
most people have heard of at least the
John campia show now I will say this
before we get into what he said about
the casting for the Invisible Woman John
is the one who had the leaked photos of
Spider-Man no way home and he does know
a lot of people in the industry so I'm
sure he has heard some legitimate
information and what he has stated on
his Show recently yesterday in fact is
that Jody Comer is indeed going to be
playing the invisible woman that's at
least what he has heard from what what
he calls a reliable source also wait
till you hear the rumor about who's
playing the Human Torch it's very
interesting but going back to sue storm
I like this Choice a lot I think it's a
great choice and as you can see in some
edited photos of her as Sue storm she
looks really good but I've really liked
her as an actress in the projects that
she's been in most recently free guy
with Ryan Reynolds and this makes sense
because free guy technically was a
Disney film since Disney owns the studio
that made free guide so she's already
technically worked for Disney in the
past it makes sense that she would be on
their radar and again I think this is a
golden choice now for the rest of the
Fantastic Four the recent rumor has it
that out of all of the names that have
been listed lately some aren't what we
think we've heard a ton of names thrown
out there we've heard John Krasinski but
he's not playing Mr Fantastic Henry
Cavill names like Denzel Washington John
boyega a bunch of different names and it
got really confusing but apparently the
recent report and what I've heard
recently is that John Krasinski is still
going to be playing the main mcu's Mr
Fantastic now this report is kind of
contradicting to what some other
insiders have said but to me it just
makes sense they have all listed his
name on an actor that they've heard to
be joining Marvel Studios so how could
it not be for Mr Fantastic that would be
confusing especially since he really
does make the perfect Reed Richards if I
had it my way I would keep him as Mr
Fantastic and the latest rumor says that
that's exactly what Marvel Studios is
going to do hopefully alongside Jody
Comer as we just talked about and Seth
Rogen as the thing now we have talked
about this before there have been rumors
going around for months now that Seth
Rogen could be playing the thing now I
have mixed feelings about this there's
some stuff I really like from Seth Rogen
there's some stuff I don't like from him
but keeping in mind that if he truly is
cast as the thing he will be in a mocap
suit and it will be CGI the entire time
I think it'll be okay because I think
the chemistry between John Krasinski and
Seth Rogen would be great both of these
actors have the capability to be
extremely funny but we've also seen both
of these actors extremely serious before
which I think is what the Fantastic Four
is going to need because it's funny they
are funny people but they are at the
same time very serious people after all
Reed Richards is the smartest man alive
so you can't go all out funny it just
can't be comedy all the time there has
to be a lot of seriousness to it and I
think these two actors with Jody Comer
can definitely pull this off but I
definitely want to hear from you all
what do you think about this if it's
true do you think it's a good call Seth
Rogen as the thing now the recent rumor
also states that Johnny AKA The Human
Torch is going to be played by Ross
Lynch now not going to lie I had to
Google this name I was not sure who Ross
Lynch was now once I looked him up I
realized that he is Austin from Austin
and Ally the show that was on the Disney
Channel so here is kind of the same case
as Jody we have Disney connections here
and he's also in the band R5 now he's
definitely a younger actor in this cast
that we're going to have but that that
makes sense because Johnny is Sue's
younger brother also in the comics Reed
is considerably older than Sue so all of
this casting here actually kind of works
and if they want a young kind of not
immature but a cocky Johnny Storm which
he typically is Ross Lynch might not be
a bad choice if he can deliver on the
acting again I haven't really seen much
from him now this kind of goes in line
with what we've been hearing for over a
year now about the casting for the
Fantastic Four that it's going to be
some big name actors and some small name
and this works so this could be our
official cast for The Fantastic Four
which could be announced in a couple of
days and based off of what I've been
hearing it looks like that could be
likely now we have more to talk about
but first thank you to best fiends for
sponsoring this video I think we all
know how much pressure life can put on
us sometimes and I know it's really easy
to put off having a little bit of
relaxation time and a little bit of fun
but that shouldn't be how it is and with
best fiends and exciting puzzle
Adventure game you can have fiendish fun
anywhere anytime best fiends is an
awesome puzzle game that I truly enjoy
because it's not just connecting in
straight lines but you can actually
connect diagonally which is a lot more
fun and you can play it anytime because
it's super quick to play and you level
up very very easily in fact the first
time I played it for only a few minutes
I got all the way to level six that's
because this game is really easy to just
pick up and get in the zone because it's
super fun one second you're on level one
and then the next thing you know you've
connected enough times to get to level
six and there are literally thousands of
different levels you can play and the
best part is best fiends is free to
download so don't put off your fun time
anymore you've definitely earned it go
to the app store or Google play to
download best fiends for free plus earn
even more with five dollars worth of
in-game rewards when you reach level 5.
that's best fiends without the r now the
next big one that we have to talk about
is Henry Cavill now we've heard a lot of
rumors recently about Henry Cavill
joining the MCU the only question is who
exactly is he going to play and two
names have been thrown around Hyperion
and Sentry both are kind of super Man
characters so both obviously fit him
very well however the latest rumor
Narrows down to one specific role and
that role is hyperion and apparently if
this is true Hyperion could be debuting
in Loki season 2. and if this is true
this is going to be quite interesting
because it looks like they're probably
going to change his origin from the
comics and the comics he's an eternal he
gets sent to Earth as a baby as the race
of the eternals is dying and his world
was dying now Marvel Studios will
probably change his origin if this is
true because they changed the origin of
the eternals themselves and that's quite
confusing at the moment but here's
something that is really interesting
about Hyperion in his comic origin his
Universe And Another Universe collided
with another and both got destroyed and
that's kind of what is happening right
now in the MCU with incursions and
that's all going to set up to Avenger
Secret Wars so this rumor actually kind
of fits perfectly with everything that
is happening in the MCU right now now
apparently if he does appear in Loki
he's going to be the leader of the
Squadron Supreme which he is the leader
of in the comics as well how is that
going to fit into the story of Loki
season 2 we have no idea but I am super
excited to see how that works if this
rumor ends up being true and last but
not least Nova now one of the many names
that was thrown around this week was
John boyega most people know John boyega
as Finn from the recent Star Wars films
his name has been going around for some
time now as somebody that Marvel Studios
wants in the MCU and apparently he could
be playing Nova now I've also heard that
Ryan Gosling could be playing Nova as
well and Kevin feige has even stated
that he would love Ryan Gosling to be in
the MCU and recently some insiders have
listed Ryan Gosling's name as somebody
that could be cast for the MCU so this
one is kind of tricky as we have
conflicting reports but the recent
report says John boyega could be playing
Nova and I will say that I think this
would be an interesting choice I would
never picture John boyega as Nova he is
somebody that would never come to my
mind if we're talking about casting for
no other I actually really like the Ryan
Gosling casting but if John boyega is
cast as Nova I'm definitely going to
give him a chance because if Marvel
Studios as Kevin feige sees something in
him then that means there's something
special there but this one's kind of up
in the air right now is it going to be
John boyega or Ryan Gosling typically
the closer we get to big events like d23
the more kind of starts to slip out so
I'm actually assuming that some if not
all of these rumors are actually true
but we have two days to wait and see
like I said be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news leading up
to d23 and of course at d23 and after I
feel like d23 is about to be huge I feel
like we're going to get the casting
announcements for a lot of different
projects coming up so be ready for
Saturday don't forget to like the video
and of course for live updates you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf